the basement of the house is not where
zantvi
had ever hoped to be but the pandemic
and financial problems forced
the founder of the all-female station to
reduce the staff
and cut costs and when the targeted
killings of journalists began
some women left and others were told by
their families to stop working
so hamid samar asked the government for
help
this is the message of the government
for all the tv stations buy the weapons
by yourself we will give you the license
but even with the license that we bought
that weapons but even with the license
we need to just wait for the government
that when they are
issuing the actually they promote the
the
permit for the weapons the license
zantv went on air in 2017 with 70 staff
and only a few men the international
community and afghan officials
pledged support but now all that has
changed
this is zantv's new control room from
where journalists are supposed to be
broadcasting their programs
it's small and basic not only because
the new facilities are limited
but also because only half of the
original staff
remain at the station
about a dozen of them work out of
another kabul station
while they wait for security to improve
and move
to their new facilities eighty percent
of the station's programming has been
dropped
and it broadcasts online for only a few
hours a week
those who are left carrying on is risky
when i leave my home my father asks me
where am i going
if i'm going to zantv who is with me if
i have my colleagues with me
not only my family but all those women
who are working in the media in
afghanistan their families are concerned
about their safety
facing threats of targeted
assassinations the women here say they
are scared
but refuse to stop one day our
director told us that be careful
with yourselves because we face to a
treat
and after that day you know that uh
we feel like uh we will
die like we feel like that but when we
see
uh the country situation when we see our
woman those who can't work those who
need to
raise their hands so we said with
ourselves
if we stop our way so we can't raise
their hands
one local organization that supports
media in afghanistan
says seven media workers have been
killed recently within nine weeks
the director says the government must
protect and support journalists
and fears much progress in afghanistan's
media over the last
20 years could be lost more than 15
of best journalists left the country
they said goodbye and maybe tens of them
that they are working still they are
observing to change
the field of working they are observing
or they are thinking or they are making
decision how to change it
this is the catastrophe that i could i
could see it
and that's the main concert
but for now it's on tv everyone says
they'll keep the station alive
no matter how difficult that is felio
contra fury al jazeera
kabul